كان يوم أمس أحد أصعب الأيام منذ تفشي المرض
الحرب نحن
لقد فقدنا 24 من أفضل أبنائنا
يجري The Heroes Chahal فحصًا شاملاً للكارثة
يجب أن نتعلم الدروس المستفادة من رينو
حادثة صعبة انهار فيها مبنيان على قواتنا
الذين عملوا في وسط قطاع غزة خلال نشاطهم
نتيجة انفجار ظهر بعد ظهر اليوم في الوفات
حماس لا نعرفها مع إرهابي واحد أو اثنين
لم يتم القضاء على المزيد من فرقة هؤلاء الإرهابيين ولا
تم القبض عليهم وتمكنوا من الفرار وأطلقوا النار على الأقل
آر بي جي واحد يضرب آر بي جي الدبابة التي تؤمّن القوات
من الاحتياطيات يؤذيه وهو أيضا ملئها
نيكيم نعم، وكان هناك قتيلان وجرح اثنان أ
نتيجة انفجار
يقوم خزان الانفجار ببدء المواد المتفجرة
المادة المتفجرة التي ليس من المفترض أن تنفجر نتيجة لذلك
مثل هذا الانفجار ومن ثم الكارثة تحدث بالفعل لأنه يوم الاثنين
تنهار المباني على جنود الاحتياط وبعد ذلك
وتبدأ عملية الإنقاذ التي لا تزال مستمرة ولا شك أن الدبابة
أصيب بصاروخ آر بي جي أصابه وقتل اثنين من المقاتلين
الدرع والجرح الثاني أي على مسافة 600 ـ 600 متر
من الحدود وعلى مسافة حوالي كيلومتر واحد من الكيبوتس
وكان كيسوفيم لا يزالون إرهابيين مسلحين في آر بي جي
وهكذا إذا كان لدى أي شخص شكوك حول هذا النشاط
مع هذا الإجراء ضروري فمن الواضح أنه ضروري
صور من اليوم الدرامي في الكنيست والتفاصيل
من اللقاء مع رئيس الوزراء في مقال ميا
هايدن، أنتم يا رفاق تموتون هناك أطفالنا حديثي الولادة
لكم جميعا إذا كنت تعتقد أن أي شخص يستطيع ذلك
دعهم يقولون ما هم عليه
يريدون بضع دقائق بعد اقتحام دين الكنيست
نقابة أبيب تل شوهام هو شاطئ في غزة بالفعل 108
مرت الأيام وركضنا في تمريض 30 شخصًا
وبدأنا نتحدث ونصرخ
والقول بأنه لا توجد طريقة لا يوجد بها الشكل اليوم
الكنيست ستتذكر المختطفين كل يوم، ولكن ليس كلهم
يومًا ما سنجد شيئًا آخر لنفعله، أريدك
ابني لا يعيش في خزانة ولا في منزل أسود
حصلنا على هاتف جديد من مختطف آخر
الذي قتل
اجعل الآن عامًا من أيام الانتظار المثيرة للأعصاب
جلبت عائلات دون رؤية أحبائهم
اختطفت هذا الصباح إلى اللجنة المالية في الكنيست وأنا
أريد أن أؤكد لجميع أفراد الجمهور هنا أنني لست كذلك
سأغادر وأطارد واحدًا تلو الآخر حتى تتعاون معنا
لأنهم جميعًا بحاجة إلى إعادتهم الآن الآن الآن
الآن يشعرون بالقلق الشديد إذا لم يكن هناك اتفاق
الخاطفون السود في الأفق لقد وصل اليأس اليوم
يا أعضاء الكنيست، أنتم لا تفهمون أن هناك أشخاصًا بينهم
الأسر التي سبق لها أن فعلت على مستوى أنهم لا يعرفون
ماذا تفعل مع نفسها ما رأيته في اللجنة المالية
إنها مجرد بداية الأشخاص المدينين للقيام بالأشياء
العث